[Aplausos]
[Música]
rusia celebrando unas elecciones
presidenciales suena como corea del
norte celebrando el día de la paz un
oxímoron sin embargo al menos sobre el
papel este año 2018 los rusos tendrán la
oportunidad de elegir si quieren volver
a tener a vladimir putin durante seis
años más
[Música]
no significa que si putin ganara estos
comicios sería el líder que más tiempo
ha pasado dirigiendo los designios del
país sólo superado por stalin y ya sé lo
que estáis pensando es muy injusto decir
que putin es un dictador cuando en
realidad se está presentando unas
elecciones junto a otros siete
candidatos y si habéis oído bien en
estos comicios vamos a tener a nada
menos que a ocho aspirantes al título de
presidente de la federación rusa
el problema que ninguno de los
opositores a vladimir putin tiene la más
remota posibilidad de ganar según todas
las encuestas de intención de voto putin
tiene una popularidad de entre un 70 y
un 75 por ciento el siguiente en el
ranking de popularidad a duras penas
roja del 15% por cierto que se trata de
un señor que se llama la dimar
yirinovski y que se presenta a las
elecciones con anuncios como éste con
más strong es ya si me convierto en
presidente
este trineo volver a andar
[Música]
se mueve no puede ser está parado
vamos chau ser yo no sé si no excluye
todo irá mejor no hace falta añadir nada
más veréis os voy a dar un consejo por
si alguno de vosotros quiere llegar a
ser dictador de su país el secreto de un
buen régimen autoritario consiste en dar
la impresión de que hay elecciones
libres
incluso en corea del norte se celebran
elecciones parlamentarias cada cuatro
años y por supuesto hay distintos
partidos políticos que se presentan pero
no os equivoquéis que haya varias
alternativas al poder establecido no
significa ni muchísimo menos que el
dictador de turno no tenga un poder
absoluto para nada el truco está en que
los otros partidos o los otros
candidatos no tengan ninguna posibilidad
bien porque no les conoce ni su padre o
porque la propia ley no les deja hacer
campaña
[Música]
y os preguntaréis qué pasa si a pesar de
todo surge un político con suficiente
apoyo popular como para desafiar al gran
líder pues bien ese es el ejemplo de
alexéi navalni la pesadilla de vladimir
putin habéis oído bien cuando parecía
que no existían alternativas políticas
en rusia naval ni ha aparecido como ese
gran líder capaz de aglutinar a todas
las distintas fuerzas de la oposición y
como decía antes que es lo que haces
cuando eres el dictador de un país y te
surge un candidato que te puede hacer
frente pues esto
el candidato crítico con el kremlin
alexéi navalni estará vetado en la
carrera presidencial sin embargo incluso
a putin tiene que tragarse sus palabras
en algún momento y los apoyos de naval
ni son suficientes como para que no esté
del todo claro que no pueda presentarse
a las elecciones así que la pregunta que
nos deberíamos hacer es quién es y
defiende realmente navalny y por
supuesto tiene posibilidades reales de
hacerle frente a putin hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
un wikileaks personal una cosa hay que
reconocerle a naval como estratega
político no tiene precio en un país
donde los dirigentes políticos tienen la
costumbre de morir jóvenes este hombre
ha sido capaz de sortear todas las leyes
rusas con maestría de cirujano en el año
2008 navalny era un abogado con cierto
prestigio que tenía ahorrados unos 300
mil rublos de la época que vendrían a
ser unos trece mil dólares y que hizo
con ese dinero es comprar
participaciones de grandes empresas
rusas
[Aplausos]
esos gigantes rusos como gazprom rosneft
lukoil son completamente opacos y es muy
difícil acceder a sus libros de cuentas
sin embargo al tener unas pocas acciones
de estas compañías naval ni podía
asistir a las reuniones de accionistas y
acceder a información que estaba
prácticamente oculta para el resto de
los mortales
así es como álex y navalny descubrió
todo tipo de tramas de corrupción tramas
que como ningún medio se atrevía a
publicar se podían leer a través de su
blog lo que pronto se convirtió en algo
mucho más popular en rusia que el propio
wikileaks
el wikileaks ruso de un solo hombre
descubre un fraude masivo en una
compañía de gas durante los años
siguientes el blog de naval y más tarde
su canal de youtube revelaron las
vergüenzas más ocultas de los oligarcas
rusos pelotazos inmobiliarios de
empresas rusas en hungría malversación
de fondos y tráfico de influencias a la
vez que su blog se volvía popular y su
canal de youtube ganaba casi 2 millones
de suscriptores napalm y sacó toda clase
de plataformas para que los ciudadanos
pudieran reportar pequeños casos de
corrupción
y creedme en lo que a corrupción se
refiere rusia da para llenar una
enciclopedia entera y qué es lo que
haces cuando te has convertido en el
héroe de la lucha anticorrupción pues te
metes en la política oficial
la campaña de naval ni trae un nuevo
estilo a la política rusa sin embargo a
diferencia de otros políticos naval ni
no se limitó a afiliarse a un partido
este hombre es algo así como un elon
musk de la política en su trayectoria ha
creado o participado en tres partidos
distintos que ha fundado incontables
movimientos ciudadanos como os podéis
imaginar el kremlin ha hecho todo lo
posible por cerrar estas plataformas o
simplemente silenciar las con todo tipo
de fraudes electorales pero navalny
siempre ha tenido capital político
suficiente como para responder
las protestas para desafiar a putin
sacar en la calle a decenas de miles de
ciudadanos los que veáis este vídeo
desde españa no estaréis muy
impresionados decenas de miles de
personas eso es una manifestación es un
grupo de amigos pero pensadlo bien esto
es rusia salir a la calle a manifestarse
requiere un extra de coraje
así que diez mil personas en las calles
de moscú san petersburgo os puedo
asegurar que son todo un mensaje y una
declaración de intenciones para el
gobierno pero sin duda alguna el punto
de inflexión en la carrera política de
naval ni vino en el año 2013
la candidatura del naval ni para la
alcaldía de moscú es aceptada tras el
veredicto al presentarse a las
elecciones para alcalde de moscú naval y
estaba lanzando un mensaje directamente
al kremlin primero tomó la capital del
país y después voy a por ti vladimir y
como os podéis imaginar el gobierno no
se quedó de brazos cruzados la policía
rusa se puso manos a la obra para
intentar sacar cualquier indicio de
delito que pudiera servir para impedir
que naval ni pudiera ser candidato
y digo indicio de delito entre comillas
porque como os podéis imaginar cuando
tienes el poder sobre la policía y los
jueces puedes modificar la verdad a tu
gusto
meses después de que naval ni anunciara
su candidatura la justicia rosa
presentaba cargos contra él por supuesto
robo de materiales en una empresa en la
que había ejercido como consultor
[Música]
exigían nada menos y seis años de cárcel
para este hombre pero la historia tenía
más agujeros que un queso gruyère así
que nuevamente esas decenas de miles de
simpatizantes salieron a la calle
amnistía internacional- se levantó en
armas y hasta el mismísimo mijail
gorbachov dio la cara para defender un
proceso electoral justo con todo y con
eso las condiciones en las que se
permitió hacer campaña naval ni eran
cómo decirlo una auténtica broma
para que os hagáis una idea su partido
no podía poner vallas publicitarias ni
tampoco anuncios en la televisión y en
un país donde casi todos los medios
están controlados por el poder político
naval ni estuvo prácticamente silenciado
en radios periódicos y televisión sin
embargo y pese a todo consiguió arañar
nada menos que un 7 por ciento del voto
por supuesto no era suficiente para
hacerse con la alcaldía pero dadas las
condiciones era toda una victoria moral
y un mensaje muy claro para el kremlin
cuidado vladimir porque te ha salido un
opositor difícil de neutralizar pero
esperad un momento porque ser el enemigo
de putin no significa automáticamente
que sea salir de la democracia y los
derechos humanos nada más lejos de la
realidad
[Música]
y defiende navalny rusia es un país
especial con unos valores muy distintos
a los de otros países por ejemplo esto
que veis aquí son imágenes del anuncio
que ha sacado el kremlin para animar a
los ciudadanos a votar en el vídeo se
muestra la distopía en la que se podría
convertir el país y la gente no vota lo
que tiene que votar y mirad qué es lo
que más temen los rusos por favor
prestad atención a los subtítulos porque
no tiene desperdicio
[Música]
y ahora
la cornisa con
habéis oído bien cuidado que vienen los
gays por sorprendente que parezca estos
mensajes políticos funcionan en rusia
por eso si quieres conquistar el corazón
de tus votantes tienes que adaptarte a
sus valores así que por ejemplo cuál
diríais que es la posición de naval ni
con respecto al conflicto de ucrania
[Música]
en la política exterior rusa debería
dirigirse a la integración con ucrania y
bielorrusia en realidad somos una única
nación y deberíamos ampliar la
integración pero no sólo eso naval ni ha
participado en toda clase de eventos
donde se celebra la raza rusa como ya
sabéis rusia es un país enorme con
decenas de etnias y religiones distintas
los rusos como tal blancos y con ojos
azules son simplemente la etnia
mayoritaria y hay varios grupos
ultranacionalistas que quieren cerrar
las puertas a los inmigrantes de otras
razas eso incluye a los musulmanes que
viven en chechenia oa los tártaros
muchos de estos grupos apoyan a putin
pero otros no pues lo cierto es que
naval ni se lleva demasiado bien con
estos grupos que siendo racistas no
apoyan a putin de hecho el programa con
el que se presentaba a estas elecciones
de 2018 proponía toda clase de
restricciones a la inmigración
la gente no está asustada con mis
principios solo les asusta la palabra
nacionalismo alexéi navalni pero sin
duda alguna la propuesta que más
ampollas ha levantado en los últimos
meses ha sido el llamado impuesto a los
oligarcas como sabéis tras la caída del
comunismo rusia privatizó casi todas las
empresas estatales pero lo hizo de tal
forma que sólo una élite de oligarcas
conectados al gobierno se pudieran hacer
con la titularidad de estas compañías
recordáis este otro vídeo en el que os
contaba el modelo de privatizaciones de
ucrania pues en rusia pasó algo muy
parecido
ahora esos grandes gigantes como gazprom
lukoil cuentan con toda clase de
privilegios políticos sus dueños están
entre las mayores fortunas del mundo y
navalny proponía un impuesto especial
para estas fortunas que podía llegar
hasta el 80 por ciento de su renta y
como os podéis imaginar estas medidas
han desatado no sólo las iras de putin
sino también de todos los aliados
políticos por eso desde que naval y ha
anunciado su candidatura para estas
elecciones para las elecciones
presidenciales de 2018 la policía no ha
dejado de hostigar les
desde publicar sus correos electrónicos
privados hasta rociarle la cara con un
spray de pintura verde y mientras tanto
los antidisturbios han reprimido todos
los intentos de manifestaciones de apoyo
a naval me y por si todo esto no fuera
suficiente los tribunales han reabierto
el caso de corrupción por el que quería
meterle en la cárcel en el año 2013
sin embargo y como decíamos al principio
está mal ni sabe jugar con todos los
recovecos de la legislación rusa y tiene
capital político suficiente como para
que sea imposible silenciarle
[Música]
a día de hoy toda rusia le conoce y sabe
que se quiere presentar a las elecciones
tus apoyos se reparten por todo el
territorio nacional no solamente en
moscú
[Música]
es cierto que pese a todo su popularidad
no llega ni a la mitad de vladimir putin
pero veréis os voy a dar otro consejo
por si alguno de vosotros llega a ser
dictador algún día cuando todo el mundo
conoce ya a tus enemigos políticos
meterles en la cárcel sólo sirve para
crear martínez y no hay nada más
peligroso para un gobernante autoritario
que tener a un mártir como enemigo
el líder de la oposición rusa alexéi
navalni liberado tras ser arrestado
durante unas protestas
así que ahora la pregunta es creéis que
naval terminara pudiéndose presentar a
las elecciones y una segunda pregunta lo
más probable es que aunque terminará
siendo aceptado como candidato perdería
los comicios pero podría llegar a
construir una fuerza de oposición
importante que pueda hacer sombra a
putin en el futuro que creéis que pasará
podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto si queréis
entender por que putin es tan popular en
rusia os lo explicamos en este otro
vídeo y como siempre no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribirse a visual político
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like compartiendo con
vuestros amigos y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]